alors j'ai essayé en préparant cette
émission de me mettre dans le cerveau de
bruno le maire un j'ai pas réussi et
deux je ne sais pas exactement ce qu'il
avait en tête j'y étais préparé cité
spontanée vous savez moi je j'aime pas
la post rationalisation je sais pas ce
qui est sûr c'est que ça a ému ce a
entraîné un certain nombre de
discussions et de mise au point assez
clair d'ailleurs aux questions au
gouvernement
daniel bizien vous l'avait dit et gérald
darmanin jeu on peut couper les phrases
et les expressions moi ce que j'ai
entendu c'est si et seulement si en
l'occurrence la croissance est au rendez
vous et donc aussi que grâce à nos
réformes économiques et fiscales on
arrive à soutenir cette croissance et à
relancer l'emploi dans notamment
l'emploi marchand dans les entreprises
on peut logiquement espérer qui aura
peut-être moins besoin de prestations
sociales en termes de masse
voilà ce que moi j'ai compris bon j'ai
pas entendu parler de suppression des
aides sociales et d'ailleurs j'ai plutôt
entendu gérald darmanin et agnès buzyn
confirmé qu' aucune aide sociale
personnalisés ne seraient concernés
toucher ou même à raboter ce mot que je
déteste dans les années qui viennent
donc je pense que on ya aussi un jeu ou
peut-être qu'on a mal compris ou et/ou
que on a prêté des intentions qui sont
pas forcément celles de bruno le maire
en revanche ce que je porte aussi comme
jugement c'est que c'est important on
aime la république en marche on essaie
d'avoir quand même un discours assez
lucide assez cash comme on dit
aujourd'hui sur les aides aux
entreprises quand gérald darmanin
répondu en précisant un que les aides
sociales personnalisée ne serait
absolument pas aux à l'ordre du jour
mais deux qui on avait le droit d'ouvrir
des réflexions sur un certain nombre des
des no tamment des deux entreprises
voiture rapporteuse spéciale entreprises
je ne m'interdis pas et je comprends les
réflexions des ministres ce qu'il ya
c'est qu'aujourd'hui ouvrir un sujet on
a le sentiment que c'est l'arbitré
on ouvre un sujet sur les aides aux
entreprises c'est aujourd'hui à peu près
140 milliards d'euros 140 milliards
d'euros c'est dix fois le budget du
ministère de l'intérieur par exemple
mans et si on met les niches fiscales et
compagnie on peut atteindre des chiffres
qui sont plutôt du double hauteur de 300
milliards d'euros
gérald darmanin annonce par exemple
qu'on peut envisager dans le quinquennat
de diminuer de 5 milliards d'euros les
aides à certaines entreprises
c'est assez peu en termes de masse par
rapport à la masse globale
et deuxièmement qu'est ce qu'on est en
train de faire on n'est pas en train
d'envisager de couper des aides on met
tous les chantiers sur la table on
travaille sur les taxes de production on
travaille avec le pacte sur
l'amélioration de la fiscalité des
entreprises donc ce que je veux dire
c'est qu'on ne se prive d'aucune
réflexion en matière d' être social
personnalisé on est refermé le dossier
pour les aides aux entreprises ont
louvre